- [Mark] Okay, so Matthew, where ya from?
- West Virginia.
- [Mark] What part of West Virginia,
Appalachian part of West Virginia?
- [Matt] Yes, Princeton.
- [Mark] Princeton, so that's
the farthest west part.
- [Matt] Yes.
Right beside of Virginia.
- [Mark] Yeah, no, it's a
beautiful part of the country.
- Oh, it's beautiful.
- [Mark] You miss it?
- I miss it a lot.
- [Mark] Can I ask you to
speak a little bit louder
so I can (indistinct).
- I miss it a lot.
- [Mark] Yeah, no, it's an
amazing part of the world.
- Yes it is.
- [Mark] And what brought
you out to California?
- I was in Arizona and couldn't get ID.
- [Mark] Couldn't get what?
- ID.
- [Mark] Oh, you couldn't get an ID?
- Yeah, somebody, 27 years ago in Arizona,
got ahold of my birth certificate
and obtained an Arizona driver's license.
But they don't have no record
of who they gave it to.
I don't see how that's possible.
You don't just hand out driver's license
with no picture, right?
So they wouldn't give
me ID, but I've had a ID
everywhere else, though.
- [Mark] How?
- I've had ID in Arizona,
Oklahoma, Kansas,
Florida, New Mexico,
everywhere I've been at,
West Virginia I had ID,
Virginia, Pennsylvania,
it's just Arizona who's messing me over.
- [Mark] All right.
- But I came out here and
got my ID with no problems.
- [Mark] Okay.
What was your line of work?
What were you doing for a living?
- I did restaurant work.
- [Mark] Okay.
And how old are you?
- I'm 51 years old.
- [Mark] Fifty-one.
Now you're down here on Skid Row.
How'd you end up down here?
- That's the only place to
go when you're homeless.
- [Mark] Hm.
- That's where all the shelters are at.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Mark] You can get fed here, and-
- You can get fed here, get housing here,
yeah, medical.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, so.
- [Mark] That's pretty rough
on the streets, though.
- Oh yeah.
I've seen people hurt here really bad.
- [Mark] Like what have you seen?
- I've seen a girl get her throat cut.
I've seen another guy
get beat with a chair.
One of them metal chairs
like you see on WWF shit?
- [Mark] Right, yeah.
- That shit's fake on there,
'cause when you get hit with a chair,
you feel it, all right?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And dude hit him four
times with a metal chair.
Caved his head in.
- [Mark] Caved his head in?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oof.
- Shit's crazy.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So a lot of drugs are going on down here.
Are you worried about any of them?
- [Matt] Oh, no.
I don't drink, I don't do
drugs, I don't do none of that.
I've been sober from
alcohol for three years.
- [Mark] You drank.
- [Matt] Oh yeah, I drank a lot.
- [Mark] So you stopped drinking?
- [Matt] Oh yeah.
- [Mark] For three years.
- [Matt] I've not had
a drop in three years.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- [Matt] Yeah.
I mean, you don't need
to be down here homeless
and being messed up on dope and alcohol.
'Cause anything could happen to you.
- [Mark] Yeah, no you,
especially as a white guy,
you're more vulnerable than-
- [Matt] Oh God, oh yeah.
- [Mark] What would you like to see happen
in the next five years for you?
- [Matt] I'm getting housing again.
I'm gonna get me another apartment.
And I'm not gonna have
friends over anymore,
'cause you see what happened with that,
I got evicted over them.
So I'm not having no more
friends over my house.
You can't trust people now.
- [Mark] Your family?
- [Matt] My mom lives in West Virginia,
my dad lives in Oklahoma.
- [Mark] Okay.
And you want to go back there,
you want to stay in California?
- [Matt] I'm gonna try
and stay in California.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Matt] I like the weather here.
- [Mark] Yeah, the weather's great.
- [Matt] Yeah.
Are you from California?
- [Mark] I'm from Chicago originally.
- [Matt] That's--
- [Mark] Detroit, Chicago, and then LA.
- [Matt] It's cold there.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- [Mark] Oh yeah, cold.
As a kid what did you dream about?
When you grew up, what you wanted to be.
- A truck driver.
- [Mark] A truck driver.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Have you driven a truck?
- No.
- [Mark] Never?
- I've been in trucks,
but I never drove one.
- [Mark] You ever been married?
- No.
- [Mark] No kids?
- [Mark] No girlfriend?
- No.
- [Mark] Stay out of trouble that way.
- Oh yeah.
I've not been in trouble since 2000, so...
- [Mark] What trouble did you get in then?
- Stealin' cars.
- [Mark] Oh you were stealing cars?
- That was my--
- [Mark] You end up in prison?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] How many years
were you in prison?
- Last time I was there was, uh,
fourteen months ???
- [Mark] What state?
- Oklahoma.
- [Mark] Oklahoma.
- Arizona, I was there before that.
I was there for four and a half years.
I was locked up in
Virginia for four years.
I've been locked up in West Virginia.
- [Mark] Oh.
- I did a year in Pennsylvania.
- [Mark] Oh!
- Yeah.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] You like cars.
- Yeah, I like cars.
- [Mark] You like other people's cars.
- Yeah.
I have a thing with
other people's vehicles.
- [Mark] Okay. And how
do you break into it?
- They were unlocked.
- [Mark] They were unlocked and you just--
They were unlocked and I just went
on and got on in 'em.
- [Mark] Hot wired?
- Hot wired 'em and I was gone.
(Mark laughs)
- You can disconnect the alarm easy.
- [Mark] Yeah, makes it easy to--
- All you gotta do is raise your hood
and there's two wires there
which ones you click is what
cuts off your alarm, all right?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. My brother taught me that.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Well, thank you for talking to me.
I appreciate the time.
All right. Thanks, man.
- [Mark] How many cars have you stolen?
- I've stolen over a hundred I know.
- [Mark] Over a hundred cars?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] At what age did you start?
- 'Bout fourteen.
- [Mark] Fourteen years old you
stole your first car?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You don't even have a driver's
license at fourteen.
- No, I never had a
driver's license in my life.
- [Mark] You still don't
have a driver's license?
- No. I can't get a driver's license.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- Somebody in Arizona
got ahold of my birth
certificate and obtained an Arizona
driver's license, but they don't have no
record of who they gave it to.
How is that even possible?
So I couldn't even get an ID in Arizona.
- [Mark] So you don't even have an ID
to get a driver's license
in the first place?
- Well I have an ID here in California.
I have an ID.
Arizona wouldn't even let me get an ID.
Arizona is just messed up.
- [Mark] So, tell me about the
Porsche that you stole.
- Well, I went into the hospital,
because my mom works there.
I was gonna get some money from her
to go buy some weed, right?
I leave the hospital,
doctor rolls right up in this Porsche.
Rolls right up, lefts it runnin'
and runs in the hospital.
Leaves it runnin'!
Shit, I jumped in that sum bitch
and I took off!
I took it to North Carolina
and I got rid of it.
- [Mark] For how much?
- Five thousand.
- [Mark] Five thousand
bucks you sold the Porsche?
- Yep.
It wasn't mine, I didn't care.
It's probably worth a lot
more than that though.
- [Mark] What?
- The Porsche.
- [Mark] That's funny.
- Uh huh.
- [Mark] And is it
exciting stealing a car?
The adrenaline and all the--
- Yeah.
It's definitely a rush.
- [Mark] It's gotta be exciting, right?
- It's definitely a rush
to steal somebody's car.
But I never car jacked
nobody though.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Never done that.
- [Mark] You're stealing cars that have
nobody in them.
- Yeah, yeah.
Car jacking, that's serious time there.
- [Mark] What's the most money you ever
made selling a car?
- (mumbles)
- [Mark] What's that?
- Twelve thousand.
- [Mark] Twelve grand? For what?
- A Lincoln.
- [Mark] A Lincoln?
- A brand new Lincoln.
- [Mark] And the people you're selling
them to know that they're hot, right?
- Oh yeah. They take 'em to a chop shop.
They know the sum bitches are stolen.
They don't care.
All they're gonna do
is chop 'em up anyway.
- [Mark] Oh.
Interesting.
- You ain't ever stole a car?
- [Mark] I've never stolen a car.
- Wow.
(Mark laughs)
- Have you ever thought about it?
- [Mark] No, I've never
even thought about it.
Maybe I should.
- No.
They give out serious time
for stealing cars now.
- [Mark] How many years in jail, prison,
have you done for stealing cars?
- Eight years.
- [Mark] Eight years?
- Uh huh.
- [Mark] What's it like in prison?
What state were you in prison?
- I've been in prison in
four different states.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- West Virginia, Virginia,
Arizona, and Oklahoma.
- [Mark] And what's it like?
- Virginia was really messed up.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- I was in maximum security prison.
I ain't had but six years,
but I'm doin' time with m'fers that
got three and four life sentences
they ain't got shit to lose, right?
They threw me there because
when they arrested me for a car, right,
it was a truck I stole in Virginia, right,
underneath the seat was a 357 magnum.
- [Mark] Oh no.
- And they charged me with it.
It was in the vehicle I stole though.
I didn't know the damn thing was in there.
I got charged with it.
A weapons charge.
I'd aggravated it,
so they aggravated my sentence
and sent me to a maximum security prison.
- [Mark] Oh shit.
- Ended up maxin' that number out.
I did, uh, three and a half on a six.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Yeah.
And Virginia wasn't nothin' nice.
They had a riot when I was there,
they killed guards,
they killed inmates,
they burned down the kitchen,
they burned down the commissary.
- [Mark] Really?
- They just wrecked the whole yard.
- [Mark] Which prison?
- That was the maximum security prison,
South Hampton.
- [Mark] Wow.
- That was a rough place.
There was no joking there.
I seen people get stabbed, beat up.
- [Mark] How do you steer
clear of all that stuff?
- The best thing to do, is you know
not to do in prison...
You don't mess with dope.
- [Mark] You don't mess with dope.
- If you can't pay for it.
You don't gamble.
You don't mess with homosexuals.
A lot of people be doin' that.
They messin' with them homosexuals
and they caught up in shit.
You don't do that.
- [Mark] There's no women around.
- These people in prison that are
dressed up like women,
they think they are women, all right?
- [Mark] Really?
Yeah, they want you to
address them as ma'am.
You know.
As female things, you
know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- They don't wanna be called men, no.
They wanna be considered females in there.
I seen it all in there though.
In Virginia I seen
everything happen in there.
But then, ya know, you been
down to Skid Row.
You seen all kinds of
crazy shit down there.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- You seen your little table set up.
Selling their little meth pipes.
- [Mark] Yeah, seen it all.
- Aw man.
- [Mark] Right there in the street.
- They don't care.
- [Mark] The cops walk right by.
- They don't give a fuck.
They got bigger fish to fry, I guess.
- [Mark] I guess.
- I never been messed with
by the police here though.
- [Mark] Well you don't look like trouble.
- Well, you're allowed to panhandle here.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So you're just a homeless guy panhandling?
You're not a threat like,
maybe some of the...
- Nah, I'm not out there
trying to get money
for dope and shit.
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah.
- Robbin' people and shit, no.
That goes on a lot here.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- That goes on a lot here in Skid Row,
a lot of robbery.
- [Mark] A lot of robbery?
- Oh yeah. -
[Mark] Oh yeah.
- They have stuff sittin' out and
m'fers walk by and snatch it, aight?
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
(gasps)
- [Mark] You walk away from your tent,
with anything valuable inside that tent.
(laughs)
Good luck.
I mean, I think what they do
is they get people high,
they give them some spice or whatever,
they get high, they pass out,
and then they rob 'em.
- [Mark] All right, man.
Well thank you for talking to me again.
Really interesting.
You got a lot of interesting stories.
You gonna steal any cars this year?
- No sir.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- I don't do nothin' wrong now.
I'm law and order.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- I don't do nothin' wrong.
I do not break the law at all.
- [Mark] But you're smoking spice?
- That's legal.
- [Mark] Ah, it's legal.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I don't think
it's good for you though.
- Well--
- [Mark] I don't, just be
careful with that shit.
- It's better than doin' meth I guess.
- [Mark] I don't know.
It's all bad.
- It's all bad.
(Mark laughs)
- Cocaine, meth, it's all bad.
Man, but what do ya do, huh?
- [Mark] Well you gotta pass
the time somehow, right?
It's good to stay busy.
- [Matt] Just keep away
from certain things.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Stay away from this neighborhood.
Stay busy.
- Fuckin' neighborhood.
- [Mark] Push the boulder up hill.
That's all you can do.
All right, man.
Thanks for talking to me!